[Music]
hey this is every damn day social media
influencers are up to something new it's
called Barbie feet so we're gonna talk
about it what that gives it a nice show
that photo whoa I guess that's how
Barbies feet are you taking ballet thank
you for asking
no I haven't but I've done a fair amount
of Pilates foot like this because she
looked like absolute dog look like a
blimp without a little leg there I guess
the theory behind it is that it does
make your legs look longer and this is a
quote from the article I read as if
you're wearing heels even when you're
barefoot hey I mean it's not the bikini
that's listening her legs
it's definitely look has anyone tried
this in their own social media presence
I have it but I've been doing the Barbie
art method with that I just keep it like
this and I got rid of my genitals I've
been doing the Barbie foot and all of my
Instagram photos however I keep
forgetting to get my entire body in the
shop just from the waist up and that boy
that joke died a sweet death the feet
aren't in the photo
what action figure or toy do people must
aspire to look like if not Barbie who
else would you like to look oh I know
troll a troll yeah what are the trolls a
troll doll
my body's so tiny that my head just
looks might be a healthier body image
for young girls to aspire to because
then I think it's at least like you've
got a big brain in there I don't - from
The Incredibles that's the body type I
[Music]
know but I was just gonna say she's very
hot well she can do the foot she's
elongated her legs they're like these
simple tricks will make you look like
her and trust me they don't I posted a
picture of bikini one time and I lost
like 24 do you think any point will get
to it like a point in our lives where
what we look like on social media is
nothing like what we look like in real
life have you ever heard of face tune no
rocks my world last summer I look great
like have you ever heard of doggy ears
filter because I same thing happened to
me last summer people are like whoa I
feel like hot girls just walk like that
in general
anyway they're just like always like
floating everywhere and plus they always
have high heels on so maybe they're
features like naturally real fat way
foot-binding thing has happened I don't
think it's a trick I think it's just
handicapped let us know what tricks you
use we want to look more beautiful
please help us we're gonna do another
thing right now
I only look at photos of your baby so
you'll have to sit through photos of my
rash I don't brush my teeth because I
think dentists are criminals
I don't like carpools because I don't
think my van belongs in water recently I
made the mistake of not being a Nazi
online there's a critical error on my
part not because those shitty views have
merit but because I opened myself up to
the dreaded Facebook argument arguing
online is truly one of the worst things
about our society unless you disagree
then leave a comment and we can do the
devil's dance together if you're like me
though disagreeing with someone online
is the quickest way to enter a living
hell of your own making short of
deciding to eat at a Golden Corral I'm
personally not cut out to argue online I
went to school for English however
debating online is it's mostly terrible
because you make your case whatever it
is and then you wait you just you wait
and waiting sucks you wait and you wait
all the while you're not breathing ha ha
ha
it's clinched and you run all the
scenarios in your head
how could anyone disagree with you your
point is ironclad logical sourced fact
checked objectively true after all
everyone knows a hot dog as a sandwich
nevertheless you go over the counter
arguments hot dogs for everyone who's
paying for that
what is this Finland I'd better find
more sources I'll get one from Fox News
that'll show them that's impossible love
though because their whole website is
just stories about teachers having sex
with their students and so you just
brood you refresh and you brood and
refresh and brood oh I'm mad now I dare
you to post something back you sad sack
go jump in the lake or eat at Golden
Corral everyone else is so dumb how dare
they think they're dumb thoughts this
guy probably just stares at his phone
all day whoever this loser is
oh wait am i that loser I better put my
phone down and think about this for
three minutes until I do all this over
again then by some kind of miracle woven
and you've got a notification that
little red bubble you've been waiting
for and it's red it's so red and red
makes me mad I hate red why is it red
red make Ryan mad red be warm and you
look to see it's show time baby you're
ready
you've got your sources your quips you
click on that little red bubble and boom
they posted a gif of a rollerblading dog
I just wish there were a version of
arguing online that wasn't so brutal and
hurtful like flag football but for
racism but for now we all have to
comment wait and repeat so I ask you is
a hot dog a sandwich I say yes hope I
didn't start an argument yeah everyone
do their best Barbie foot a Barbie foot
stinks higher hi everyone best Barbie
foot innocent
[Music]
you